WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Have you
ever been watching a video
on Android TV, but you still
wanted to browse around
to look for something new?
Then you need to use the
new Picture-in-Picture mode,
available in Android N.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Wayne Piekarski from Google.
And today, I'm going to talk
about Picture-in-Picture
on Android TV and how to
quickly support it in your apps.
Picture-in-Picture,
also known as PIP,
is a new feature available
in Android N on Android TV
devices.
PIP builds on the new
Android and multi-window APIs
to bring you an intuitive,
multi-window experience,
specifically designed
for Android TV.
With Picture-in-Picture
enabled in your app,
users can continue
watching your content
while they browse more
content in app and across apps
on Android TV.
The user selects the PIP icon to
put the video in the top right
corner.
PIP also helps your
users return to your app.
So while they browse around
for different content,
it's now quick and easy for
them to return to your app,
even if they're in a
completely different app.
Without PIP, once the user
leaves your app, they're gone.
If you press and
hold the Home button,
it'll bring up the
Recents list, which
allows you to make the PIP
full-screen or to stop it.
In order to support
PIP in your app,
there are few simple changes
that you'll need to make.
The first to do
is you need to add
these few lines to your payback
activity in your manifest file.
This tells Android that your
activity is specifically
designed to go into
PIP mode and can
be resized by the system
when PIP is enabled.
We suggest you only add
these tags to video playback
activities, as they
provide the best user
experience for PIP mode.
And this is what users will
come to expect from the feature.
Next, add a button to
your UI so that your users
can activate PIP.
If you're using the
leanback support library,
we've already added a new
Picture-in-Picture action
class that allows
you to easily drop
a PIP button into your
existing playback controls row.
When the button
is clicked, simply
run activity
enterPictureInPictureMode
and Android will
handle the rest.
At any time, you can
call the activity
isInPictureInPictureMode method
to detect whether your activity
is in PIP mode.
For example, when you
switch to PIP mode,
your activity is
considered to be paused.
So you should continue
video playback
and pause everything else.
If you find that your video
pauses when you activate PIP,
that's likely because you're
handling the play and pause
logic in onResume and onPause.
In Android N, we recommend
your play-pause logic happen
in onStart, onStop instead.
So be sure to move that
logic over to those methods
if you encounter that issue.
Finally, you may notice
that your Playback Controls
row still shows up
in the PIP window.
This may confuse users.
So we'll need to hide
those when we into PIP mode
and show them again
once we exit PIP mode.
If you implement the
media session properly,
then play and pause controls
on the remote control
or the Recents list will
still work on the PIP.
Simply override the
onPictureInPictureModeChanged
in your activity or fragment,
and hide your controls
if you're in PIP mode.
And that's it.
You're done.
Your app now supports
PIP and is ready to use.
Here's a few extra
tips that will
help make sure your
Picture-in-Picture experience
is polished for your users.
First, use the Android
launchMode="singleTask"
on your PIP enabled activity
to make sure you're PIP window
automatically closes when a user
starts playing a new video from
within your application.
We suggest you use the
Picture-in-Picture window
only for displaying
your video content,
as this provides the
best user experience.
And finally, when you reach
the end of your video,
you should either autoplay a
next video, or close the PIP.
But don't go back to the
full-screen user interface.
So go and check out
our leanback sample,
which shows you a full
implementation of how
to incorporate
Picture-in-Picture in your app.
Picture-in-Picture mode
provides your users
with a great experience for
viewing and browsing content
at the same time on Android TV.
As you saw, enabling
PIP in your apps
is easy and can help your users
stay engaged with your content
beyond the confines of your app.
So that's it for today.
Try out the PIP
support in the sample.
And join us in our G+ community
to discuss this and other
Andriod TV APIs.
I'm Wayne Piekarski.
And I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]